lei siamo dietro c'è un problema amico
era costruito la partita grande meno ma
la vergine
siamo con pietro io scelgo il cavallo
dai scegliete l'iceberg come mappa forte
ma scusami se la cosa va bene giochiamo
con pietro
ciao amico eccoci lì ma perché se con
due persone non lo so ma l'altro lo poi
muoversi guarda con arma come perfetto
se pensate che non riesco a sopportare
nella mia vita neanche un pietro adesso
ne ho due
questo per noi io e questo prendo io va
bene vai
no no mi posso vincere ancora e
ripartito va bene ma con l'aiuto mi con
boom ai colli con la cosa che sa tanca
non si stanca ostia nessun vincitore
base al bravi bel casino
e va beh eccomi incastrare le cose non
si incastrata attenzione no no no non ha
paura di quella fatta ma il pollo
vincerà fai schifo paradis che ti fa
paura il bollo il pollo io posso mai
perdere contro pietro ragazzi da solo
solista pezzo di merda che ti rifiuti
recuperato l'ogiva rubare bella quadra
paura perché faccio schifo
no no no no no
perché da perfetto una vittoria l'ho
fatta almeno o no sì no sì sì sì sì è un
porno questo video cosa pietro mondo
morire odori e l'odore se voglio perso
se voglio perso l hai fatta ma iniziale
guarda ora resto quale quale collaboro
per festeggiarti già fatta no è il pollo
andato
no perché lei capri storico eric aubin
ci vogliono personaggi ci posso credere
l'aria cell elica l'elica del coso 6
lacrime da ceppari di di pavè cioè sei
riuscita a vincere con le mani un peso
che legati uccidesse a cagare per la bei
prossimo play travis con la faccia in
serata sera si senta come prima che io
due adesso io il cavallo sono un per
facciamo loro non duri solo un player va
bene io sono il pollo io sono un
elefante amico mio 1 contro 1 stavolta
siamo ok sono morte e morto io no perché
non ho vinto niente
così perché zuma disponeva beh mica
aggiungono difficoltà si zooma lo
schermo da solo ma si fa a vincere star
ops il valore di allora parco demonio è
difficilissimo ci sono
aiuto ok madonna quanto è difficile ci
sono chance è arrivato d'altra parte
parte non ci passa qui dentro amico o
che rido anch'io credo che sono andata
quindi qua soffitto quasi come sono
finito qua per l'aiuto amico perché sono
qui io eccoti ciao ciao dovremo andare
18 soffitto 2 posto vedendo attenzione
arrivato così alla fine guardalinee che
questa roba da lì al suo dio guarda ora
che sono amico non valotti del ponte è
perché troppo grasso non ci passi falsi
condizioni che ho fatto sono riuscito a
vincere anche fatto ripartire
vai vai che ci ha mai anch'io civico no
ma può essere così idiota di omino ti
sei fatto tutto sto giro per niente anno
gioca lì vello d onore perché adesso ci
mettiamo pure gli ostacoli facciamo
perché così non possiamo vincere noi che
non chiude mai dai la regola
bravo ma non è questa la mia danza della
vittoria
devo arrivare alla fine però ci possa
arrivare allora guardami vincere basta
guardare ma da anni al mio forte io
forte allora qui qualcosa serve non lo
so però prendo lo stesso le monete ciao
non puoi vincere
no mi sono alzato solo un idiota o se
peccato oggi uno solo della vince una
volta sola vinto o cioè che ha fatto
tutti e due da un set e morta si guarda
a un formato battuto di pile grazie
amico che stava da torcere
eva che mi spara sempre qua per le
monete perché me ne frega le monete al
boca all'inps dai vai ad alzare non
tassare maledetto aspetto amico e
profumo della sconfitta questo lo senti
puzza proprio di ditte hanno acquistato
è spuntato porca vacca ho lasciato tutto
per un attimo mi son cagando posto
pensavo di perdere è la madonna le
monete quanto danno con beck ancora una
ancora una per vincere al cuore
vai scusami buona quella c'e quella roba
lì estorta parole cose storte perché
perché la mia il matteucci sei morto va
bene va bene vincerò io questa partita
già capito no no no no no ma buona
stessa mi doveva vedere se io sono il
nostro amico sono in un sito zitto aiuto
no no no dice che già inventore di bile
è un casino come faccio dai dai dai
non puoi non scendere di stabilire per
scegliere nel salire mimato con la
cronca frana non è che fria guarda lì
c'è casino ma tu popoli dove metterla la
trappola schifosa laida giovanditto
giorni stando il dito in campana che
male ma dovrà passare riuscendo però si
no sono una minaccia c'è la ventola dai
che schifo ma fa veramente sì ma fra
tutti i posti dove poter rimettere quel
coso di ma cosa
mi sono mangiato la vittoria nessuno ci
aveva pensato di avere in pugno un
deficiente piano va a cagare pietro ciao
miei iota incredibile ciao
no quello lo sbaglio maledizione parla
di questa d'ischia time va bene allora
che pezzente adesso anche noi ci prova
arriva no quelli che non lo so sism in
chiaro e localini anche per quello sì mi
chiama perché le frecce lo colpiscono
qui a su a vincere è una festa cosa non
alla renault si vuol vincere quindi ciao
amico il mio corpo botros cui per una
freccia vorrei fare una cosa no sono
arrivata la vittoria lo prende la moneta
forse è meglio che non l'ho presa perché
morivo ma che ancora un poco non aveva
ancora finito
sarà così è malato non ce n'era giusta
c'è prima si c'era no perché il mio
corpo o da morto ha colpito una
ciao pietro vieni qua se riesci serie c
arrivare qua non convincono
eccola esatto ok non è vero ci si arriva
va bene va bene troppo piacere tra
l'altro niente.la civiltà si sparerebbe
un cretino
accetto la sfida ok
vai sei già morto a 96 morti sono morto
e niente hai vinto signori il profumo e
la vittoria non sa di pietà lo sa più di
bob sai perché perché un sacco di
ragazze le sue bussare alla mia porta
milano fa vigeva sito quello che ha
vinto a pieni te la do così come gemma
sei tu quello che ha vinto sì grazie
le me la dai sì sì vedi che funziona
pietra ed odiato in dvd è arrivato
thomas dirlo ma se lo dice thomas
ragazzi io direi che dopo questa miss
fatta del buon pietro possiamo
concludere quel video e ringrazio thoman
spero che mi ha fatto questo incredibile
offerta semplice e precisa quanto mi
piace anche ad essere venuta descrizione
se doveste chiedere ci vediamo da
ragazzi